Assassin's Creed unity is a familiar
game that makes some big changes sadly
not all of them are for the better that
doesn't mean there's not a lot to like
take the new lead on oh he's certainly
one of the most charismatic and well
active Assassin's Creed leads I've seen
in a while
[ __ ] Shaw mischievous and just enough of
a jerk to still be lovable but the story
never quite exploits his charms to the
fullest
it certainly tries though unity shiz
away from having a vast collection of
ancillary characters focusing instead
upon its lead Arno and his love interest
in Lee's but less of those supporting
characters around many of whom tended to
play a more lighthearted role the story
takes on a much darker tone just go
please
what other direction could have taken
the complex Abstergo storyline as long
sinks jump the shark and unity only
briefly ties itself into the wider
Assassin's Creed universe if you are
hoping for a deeper dive into the
modelled mysteries of Abstergo you won't
find it here the story which evolved
some love story to revenge tale to
murder mystery and then circles right
back to love story again is swiftly
paced but that all-important chemistry
between its two leads isn't strong
enough to tie the whole thing together I
cared enough to want to see things
through to the end but not enough to be
truly saddened by any of its events it's
a shame that the story doesn't tie into
the setting that deeply particularly
since unities betrayal of a paris
scarred by the civil unrest of the
French Revolution is one of its greatest
triumphs the attention to detail that's
gone into the city is nothing short of
astonishing exploring Paris's many
districts you realize that the sheer
scale of the city is incredible not only
in terms of its explorable limits but in
the huge number of citizens wandering
its streets a mission where you're
tasked with performing an assassination
among a crowd of thousands shows how
unity is as close as the series has ever
come to creating a tangible convincing
city
unity succeeds in his combat and
missions two gone is the enforced
hand-holding of old replace with
excellent sandbox style missions that
let you take on an assassination however
you like you might not succeed every
time but I'm a fan for trial and error
approach planning out the perfect
assassination route after many attempts
the replayability factor here is huge -
giving you far more of an incentive to
go back and nail those bonus conditions
for completing a mission these sand
boxes make up the bulk of unities
missions as well as the all-new 4 player
co-op mode and you know what
co-op is ok if not the go to multiplayer
mode you might have hoped for those fun
are the heist missions where your team
is rewarded the stealthiness the more
people you alert along the way the less
cash you get at the end the ability to
highlight potential kills for your
teammates as well as unlocked skills
like shared eagle vision do a great job
of reinforcing an idea of teamwork
indeed the most successful and
entertaining heist come from putting
together a very team with some members
focusing on close-range attacks and
others taking point with long-range
weapons integrating the coop into the
single-player campaign is a nice idea
and it makes some more cohesive ties
into the storyline but it also means
that the carp is a mere sidelines of the
action rather than something you'd want
to plow a lot of time into sadly the
excellent PvP multiplayer from previous
games doesn't make a return
so what else is new there's a mechanic
that creates a visible silhouette of
your last-known position making it
easier to know exactly where you've been
spotted and it also acts as a law for
enemies
there are also time anomaly missions to
play through which are neat platforming
puzzles set in different Harry the time
there's no more crafting to worry about
with skill points and hard cash lesson
you customize Arno to your heart's
content
while more freeform parkour movement
makes of fluid climbing even if it's
sometimes frustratingly flakes out and
puts you right in the path of an enemy
there are other irritations to this
content that has to be unlocked by the
web-based assassin's creed initiatory
painfully dull Assassin's Creed
companion app there are glitches that
cause MPC's to randomly walk in midair
or Arno to float between jumps and
despite whatever colloquial reasons
Ubisoft gives it's really weird to
wander around revolutionary Paris and
have every conversation play out in a
thick British accent know your heart is
set on keeping the peace but bringing
Monsieur de Lesseps killer to justice
would count for something wouldn't it
yes it would but do not confuse your
personal vendetta with a sound strategy
if he wants to kill Templars we don't
kill Templars not all of unities more
progressive touches work out for the
best but you might spend more time
noticing what's old than what's new the
terrific atmosphere of Paris the focus
on parkour and the incentives performing
stealthy assassinations all these things
hint at a game that's trying to return
to its roots
after branching out so wildly in its
past two iterations
yes unity is the most assassin's creed
to light of the series since well as
Sasson screed - and while it never hits
the dizzying heights of Ezio jaunt
through 15th century Italy unity
similarities are comforting enough to
take the edge off it's less than
successful changes is unity the next-gen
Assassin's Creed we've all been waiting
for
well not quite it's very good maybe even
great in places but the story's smaller
focus has come at the expense of this
exquisitely rendered backdrop assassin's
creed should be all about grandness and
spectacle and sadly that's sorely
lacking here
you